quick breakdown here what do we have so
far 48 players a higher average rating
for this tournament compared to last
1828 time handicap another 30-minute one
and anybody can enter no experience
level no experience level required so
let's go here what will we have let's do
it I am entered okay my clock is on out
of my way already
come on don't tell me this isn't gonna
start up okay it's starting up efore and
should I be doing d4 no matter what okay
here we go I thought it might be a
French but my opponent duped me right
there they threw in c5 it's throwing a
check and then follow up with a four
because I don't want to allow for an a6
b5 expansion Castle my knight wants to
get to c4 c4 let's go
b6 sometimes the knight would like to
make use of that b6 square but that's
ruled out and I think Queen to d3 let me
do this first so I could tuck my Bishop
back I'm on that pun why don't I just
take it now sure just taking that pun
okay let's take it now I'm gonna do it
with the pawn read the bishop so I can
recapture the night in hit f7 I'm on the
Queen no not to that I want to get on f7
I'm gonna win the Queen winning the
Queen or is she gonna go
I got a pawn at least and then I push I
want to get on the light squares
actually right here's a good spot no my
queen is dead oh well she's dead she's a
dead Queen dead Queen she was dead for a
moment oh there's not here main threat I
got the Queen's off okay okay I got I
got this right to do this first stop the
knife from playing here and then push
couple times I can't do that now okay I
gotta guard this first and then the
night is gonna do what oh I should have
just taken the rook I'm missing too many
things I want to cry just take this and
then okay I have this man so many
miscalculations geez
too many miscalculations here no time
I'm not gonna win this yeah I'm not
gonna win this on position I just have
to go for time here push push push no
time back to tournament a bunch of two's
a bunch of twos are in there okay ace
rook let's go ah the bird is the word
the bird is the word
we prepared chopped tonight and light
squares gonna take that night I'm gonna
take that night they want to try I don't
want to draw sneaky move another sneaky
move and then a fork a fork over here
uh-oh uh-oh come on move your pieces
there stick in this is ah this is awful
I have that happens those are precious
seconds precious seconds I tell you look
see - come on move move move come on
move see - next on the bishop flight
square what am i doing Queen to b5 I'm
gonna chop that Knight Queen B five pigs
one pig on the second looking for
another one flight square okay one Pig
two pigs pigs open it up get my bishop
on this diagonal somehow
let's go let's go here what's happening
over here on the other side oh the
night's gonna give a check no it's not
let's get that pond what am i doing ok
let's go here get that night out of
there you got to go oh there's a check
this is a killer this is a mating two
one two
Oh killer back to tournament 12 no
surprise don't resign to this guy
resigned to this guy I mean right here
let's go let's go let's roll
Oh Bishop c4 a5 9 f3 I'm dropping pawns
or mi castle before it's too late the
Knights gonna go there okay I'm probably
in a little bit of hot water here or am
i let's do this I have to um I'm in some
trouble
stop that knife from gone there pin the
night I gotta get rid of this guy he's
oh no oh no no no no oh man that would
have been bad who knows about that it's
happened before the adobe flash gambit
it almost happened I almost fell for the
adobe flash gambit Oh dead I'm dead I'm
dead there would have been a check oh
they could have killed me right there
the Queen Queen d4 would have been
lights out kill this rook right here I
still want the rep to get here my queen
should have done something okay good
this is good man I can't right
mouse-click I have to disable that no
use for the right mouse-click of these
war zones I wanna cry look at this five
games don't tell me there was any quick
resigner
ah now what see you kiddo they're
running in there going whoa
Oh what did I do deserve that one
they're throwing out these sneak attacks
that's a free pond could take on f7 very
soon they might want to do it I think
I'm gonna do it let's just open it up
sack time sack time 94 maybe even sack
another piece get the C file get the
palma avalanche going pon avalanche
avalanche of Pines Development King up
Queen b6 threats Oh what do we have here
oh okay well I'm not gonna get that move
in MI let's get this Jeep ongoing or
something oh that's a killer Fork got
the rookie all right the rookies dead
check let's get this this is close to me
very very close to me check not quite me
get that night out of there he needs to
go my bishop yeah
Oh move I can't move my pieces oh
there's a fork right here oh man that
would have been bad news bad news for
Team black oh man that would have been a
killer check guard this pond I don't
want to move it oh I should have moved
it move it checks checks everywhere
let's get this pond everything's gonna
be okay
come over here hang on they were being
sneaky that was a sneak attack that
could be sneaky back is this gonna work
no they're gonna Queen what check let's
hang on let's just do that for fun no
stalemates
no stalemates back to chairman 24:42 29
27 24 I have a lot of catching up to do
man how many players are in this 63 okay
let's go let's roll okay they know why
the mouse slip again more mouse lips or
in the air get out of this diagonal the
rook is on it a pond go after the king
move the knight get in b4 b4 incoming
let's go
attack that King get over here rook I
can't deal with that Knight
I'm on the pond forks forks and
everything everything forex till the
queen is dead resign resign
stop that knife from coming here go push
push the pond push the pond right here
I'm on the bishop made threats can you
drop that check over here
rook deliver a mate it's unavoidable the
[ __ ] a block that's me back to
Thailand 30 56 36 37 games six games and
five games in let's go to guys ahead oh
I didn't want to go with this each pun
launched it it's been launched pawn push
let's get it in right now it's thrown in
between her in there what am i doing I'm
floundering right now floundering my
knight oh man I can't move my knight or
I can't move my pawn so let me do this
first light square weaknesses light
square weaknesses pawn push okay here we
go
you've always moved my knight back I
think Oh what's happening oh I got a run
for the hills no I have a good I have a
good one right here this is this is good
I'm on the Queen I'm defending my rook
I'm defending the knight oh I'm on the
Queen but no I got to do this first I'm
back on the Queen now the queen is close
to being trapped she is trapped
she's a trapped Queen got to take my
knight who that might be good I have to
take my pawn
there's Knight takes here though
man I'm gonna do it there's no mate here
is their night right here
oh that's slick that was a slick move
okay let's get that night though how do
I get the night I'm not sure let's get
rid of let's go here light square bishop
I wanna get rid of the lights great
bishops
oh that Knights freed up now okay okay
let's go check I got the rookie let's
get this hit the rook and then oh man
I'm gonna get chased away let's do this
and then a rook here oh it's a killer
main killer mate coming up I think this
is working
no it's not no it's not oh the bishops
there to watch over stuff now it isn't
take my rope I get me take the rook I
get me sneaky move no no no no no this
is me what what back to tournament forty
to fifty five forty fifty five fifty
four forty two two guys still in the
lead both have a game or two on me let's
go here mega King let's go with E for
isee-3 Bishop c4 F for Knight f3 f7
let's guard this and then back up I
should have done that maybe now what
okay there's a lot of pressure on the F
file lots of pressure a file take that
pawn and then pin the night this is
brutal I think move my queen to the side
Queen d6 I think I want to Queen to h4
just take that night it's threatened I'm
still on the night let me just double up
first and then kill the night actually I
could probably kill the night I think I
want to do this I want to get Bishop to
see Bishop to f6 and then Bishop a queen
to eight a six they're not having any of
that okay I can still maybe get it Queen
to h6 with e5 stuff still mates somehow
rook right here and then smash through
to makin one threat me to make it to
back to term in 56 7156 54 Johnathan cm
is up there fit 71 okay let's go double
those points c5 c6 and then o clock tick
here no Smith Maura I don't want it
okay development with the tempo if I can
move the pieces east 6 and then Bishop
to b4 pin the knight get d5 in is the
plan okay there might be Queen okay I
have a nice Center I could win I could
win that pond but I dropped this or
something let me just get my Center
going here castle might be push i
reroute okay now I have a to de xira
majority the bishop coming out here
hitting the rook I'm gonna get that beep
on soon and I think I have it let me hit
this Knight
I can also hit the Queen okay let's take
this pawn first and then pile up pigs
looking for pigs around the Queen I can
get this pawn next I could get the night
let's take this double up I bit my
Bishop bone is well my bishops not doing
anything let's trade Queens it's getting
a little scary clean right here I guess
no Queen trades am I getting mated I
have this covered okay now there's what
I just want to double up 17 seconds I
don't have any time let's go here pawn
push I push back I need them some space
for my king okay let's get this pawn
going here let's go I have this covered
pig pig pig pig check no he can't go
there check again Bishop here and then
what
let's go 11 seconds checks more checks
right here check get this pond get the
night more checks okay not much time
they're out of time
that one took forever to win okay back
to tournament 70 to 89 88 72 14 minutes
and change okay
still back here top guy has nine games
let's go with E for more efore alright
let's go and I preme of that F for
looking to get an e5 something against
f7 stakeout claim on the f6 square maybe
I'm gonna try for it get my night right
here I have to watch out for Forex let
me avoid that and then get to the dark
squares my darks for Bishop wants to get
out doing something dark square bishop I
want to keep it open I have that e5
square now that's why I wanted to get
that open so let me get rid of the night
that night needs to leave soon I might
want to develop a bit more I should've
just taken it dropping this but I get
the night I think capture like this dark
squares that Bishop is still dead oh I
got the rook resignation close to
resignation here maybe take the knight
Knight g5 looking for me really really
soon mate in two threat rook f7 Rick h7
oh this is a discovered check coming up
discovery check and then a mate if pawn
push where's the mate
where does that mean oh if pond push
then I got me right here I know it's not
me now its mate next
okay back to chairman 90 108 90 90 okay
here we go
108 90 total robic big bad wolf here
okay let me get this in uh-oh we might
be having it it might be engaged
oh is that defend is that defending it
I'm gonna throw this in sneaky sneaky
stuff kill the knight Knight takes
Knight I'm on the rook I'm on the rookie
I'm on the rook oh oh let me take the
knight get this file open up oh it's a
little scary right here that bishops
gonna move am i getting trapped I'm
getting trapped oh no I'm getting I
should've taken the rook oh I'm gonna
take this guy he's more important to get
out of the game oh man this is trouble
you could do it you could do it you
could do it don't resign come on you
could fight back come on team black here
you could do it
get your knight to g3 made on each one
made on each one is what I want right
here grab a pine
sneaky stuff let's come over here h-file
get on the h-file it's really scary over
here my king is gonna have to pack up
and leave oh he's gonna have to pack up
and leave oh man it's very scary over
here very scary I just dropped my rook
no I didn't aah they dropped her quick
Oh sneaky stuff sneaky stuff oh man
that's that's a tough one
they thought my king was gonna flee he
didn't flee okay I'm on the rookie tie
the tables turn there's Forks I
should've did that I missed it
let's go with Oh sneaky not more Forks
get back here - time how much time is
left I dodged a big bullet right there
take it back to tournament land 128 110
107 10 minutes and change car j'en be
very prepared for anything in these
tournaments be very prepared anything
can happen
prepare for anything okay
oh I can't stop laughing
f5 let's just do it 9f floor coming up
oh okay
night h4 no no no no no no okay let's
get rid of this guy my night is stupid
what is he doing Wow stupid night stupid
night right here let's go here now this
pawn push I think I just want to push up
the night pushes okay I got a pawn I got
the e4 square let's get rid of the
knight get rid of that Knight f6
smashing up in the Kings side okay he's
got to go oh I can't take that pawn
that was a good move check and then me
threat they can't pin cuz they're pinned
I'm gonna take the bishop if it moves
their main threat next yes that was
pretty quick back to tournament 130 148
131 27 106 9 minutes and change am I
gonna get paired up it's gonna be a big
game I lost the last time we played come
on let's go pair me up or wait maybe
just let let it be an air that's ok let
it be an air - just give me my points I
might I might turn out yes air time give
me the points I got some points out of
it pair me up again that was good that
was good
that was good I'll take that one oh I
should have I have to hold off for these
caro-kann variations I want to go into
the fantasy variation ok wait that
bishops gonna get beat up isn't it it's
getting beat up right now oh man
light-square weaknesses killer killer
light-square weaknesses very difficult
to defend
Oh Oh Knight g5 is brutal looking for me
it's made soon I'm prepping to mate
Bishop here this is me I should just
move my Queen here that's me that was
pretty quick back to tournament 168 169
go go go eight minutes and change I can
catch them can I do it before we could
be paired up at any moment
Kings gambit I should just take that
Center they're gonna grab that pi/4
resign resign fork oh I'm still on the
night they gonna attack the pawn what am
i doing get my Bishop here Queen has to
play here no it's back up if I Castle
there could be some trouble on the
diagonal let's support this get my Night
Out queenside castle is what I want to
do oh they dropped that night come on
resign Knight f4 Knight a5 hit the Queen
get the night I'm on the knight right
now 95 I'm on the clean Forks c7 f6 you
name it right here
interference make it one threat or no
it's gonna take the night and then
where's the mate coming up soon very
soon Queen check I should have done that
take it
I want my night to get the what oh right
here next one of these two squares right
here you have to give that up
hit the Queen next maids maids maids
where the mates I don't want to Queen
trade take my bishop it's me yes doctor
term at 180 188 186 minutes and change
teen games 13 games 13 are we gonna get
paired up that would be the decider I
think maybe I think maybe okay let's do
this
I actually reviewed a game recently
where this was the variation so let's
see if I could put it to use what did
this Knight do okay yeah I came over
here to target this pawn and okay well
I'm winning that pond now okay I'm
winning this pun I'm winning a lot of
puns I'm on the Queen I should have
taken the bishop let's try it again if
that happens okay it's not happening
they get this pawn back get rid of that
night he has no business being around
there get out of there tonight he's
flush to the edge now Oh what's
happening let's come over here I think
everything's okay
or is it Bishop f6 I should have played
Bishop f6 no let's not do that
Queen trade Bishop block Bishop f6
everything's gonna be okay
Queen trade Queen trade mate close to me
they're gonna have to block resign
they're down on time anyhow and the
piece a full piece
a minor piece come on yeah it's back to
tournament 2 2 2 28 200
oh that's too tough man what do you do
so that is such a lead right there 5
minutes and change d4f 45 launched an H
pawn avoid the knight exchange I want to
play Seif okay what do we got dark
squares again I'm gonna come over here I
want my Bishop to get here quick pawn
push releases the tension the center oh
I'd get trapped if I did that what am I
doing with that move okay I want the
dark sky bishops to get off the board
G 4 F 5 g 4 F 5 coming up here we go
I have b5 covered I might play a 4 in
response to a 6 yep
okay f5 next King to each one
okay let's just go with it f6 could be a
killer move
okay the bishop is shut out of the game
dark I want to get rid of what actually
look up and over look up and over is the
plan take this first or do I even need
to do that I don't need to do that
they're gonna take my knight it better
work
I'm gonna run to the corner cuz
otherwise there's Bishop takes on f6 or
something with check and that sort of
stuff okay it's actually there it's
working
oh there's a Knight takes Knight there's
their getting saved right here crap
they're getting saved right here ah
miscalculation miscalculation check I'm
gonna be sneaky lateral movement I'm on
the Queen are they gonna see it but stop
I was trying to be sneaky sneak tactics
this is not good to be doing you should
not be trying to be sneaky here primo
primo primo robot mode robot mode free
move less than 10 primo primo primo pay
move
how much time just let the clock tick
pre move pretty move come on that clock
is taking forever to run pretty move
back to Turman to 20 to 28 to 20 did he
slip up he might have slipped up or
maybe he's just ready to win - 28 - 23
minutes in change come on pair me up
there me up pair me up am I gonna get
paired up with Oh
maxxium why'd I do that whenever I do
yes back to tournament 240 yawns two
forty eight to forty a quick resigner I
needed that boost here we go they might
come down to the wire if I could get a
quick win here and then one more maybe
quick win should I really play with that
okay I want to get g5 get that night out
of there g5 i mean ii ii ii if Knight to
g4 Bishop takes f4 95 come on I want to
get on f7 take my night take my night
I'm on f7 soon real soon just take this
and then take on f4 where's that night
gonna go f7 is a big problem here we go
f7 what do we got f7 something to f7
they're stopping f7 let's go get my
other up doing something let's take like
this and then land a discovered check
soon let's go ah how much time one forty
and forty where's that King gonna go
where's the main where's the main check
o is that's mate that's mate back to
tournament 268 261 27 126 125 124 can I
get one more in oh come back come on
come on come on pair me up oh they're
not gonna pair me up
I might get points for this can I get
some points is it gonna be enough Oh
they'd only give me four right would
they only give me four points or
something let's go I can't do anything
you got a ID you got a play to win it's
like the lottery come on throw me in
there ah let's go here let's go come on
there's only 52 seconds left fifty it's
right here look at the little clock
doesn't that make you nervous 46 45 44
40 seconds did not pay me up come on
this is a terrible way to finish who's
on my heels anybody know look at this
you just gotta stare two o'clock there
as the tournament
this is not fun here come on give me the
boost give me the boost what'd I get
yes come on let's go come on come on
come on hopefully just be a clock burner
against that guy come on quick mate
quick mate anything anything look for me
do it you could do it f7 pre-move pre
move this oh come on let me get me there
get my pin what do I go what do I got
what we got
yes oh man first-place confetti there it
is get fired up whoa I don't want a
t-shirt right did I click on something
ah first place boom just a hair up good
games off I'm in better spirits on this
one what a finish yeah whoo 270 oh man
what a final game right there it's a
good thing that it was an error the air
gave it or something oh I'm gonna take
that one